und ich bin gerade ein bisschen außer
atem wie man vielleicht hört weil ich
weiß was in apex willkommen bei einem
neuen video und zwar bis heute gedacht
das video kann man nicht gestern samstag
sollte am sonntag in das ist auch vor
allem themenbezogen so und zwar geht es
heute um sachen warum ich den sonntag
übel hasse ich muss ganz ehrlich
gestehen es gibt ja sehr viele die
hassenden montag am meisten fast alle
eigentlich aber bei mir ist das
eigentlich nicht so ich finde den montag
bis auf die schule schon okay der
sonntag ist einfach immer scheiße und
ich bin gerade ein bisschen außer atem
wie man vielleicht hört weil ich ja auf
jeden fall will ich auch gar nicht lange
drum umlagern und euch direkt mal zeigen
was ich so meine ich wette das kennt
auch sehr sehr viele von euch oder fast
alle eigentlich und zwar fangen wir
erstmal an mit so samstag morgens
aufstehen wie das bei mir aussieht dass
das muss ich unbedingt mal zeigen
geil endlich samstag etwas geht heute ja
hört sich doch gut ich habe auch
überhaupt keine flächen also heute ja
genau ich hab dich lieb
ja und so stehe ich dann halt samstags
und sonntags morgens sieht das zwar
ähnlich aus aber halt schon ein bisschen
anders und das regt mich richtig auf
sonntags zu stieß auf direkt mit einem
schlechten gefühl was ich meine
hoffmann
doch am sonntag was das geht mal so
etwas geht heute das gleiche nichts
machen so ja das ist jetzt halt eine
sache man kann sich aber vielleicht so
noch die ein oder andere hoffnung machen
dass der tag vielleicht noch ganz geil
geht man weiß ja nie
bis man dann darauf kommt das war doch
hausaufgaben machen muss ich weiß sehr
viele werden jetzt damit an komme ich
mache keine hausaufgaben aber wenn man
also ich bin jetzt mein nächstes jahr
mache ich abi und da ist es halt schon
so von vorteil ab und zu mal die
hausaufgaben zu machen deswegen frage
ich dann immer so meine mitschüler weil
ich mir das halt eher selten auf was die
auf hatten
dann muss ich halt zehn leute fragen
dass mir einer sagen kann weißt du was
du weißt nicht was wir oft haben aber
ich frage mal weiß was mach ich nicht
also auch nicht so was geht
du weißt doch bestimmt was sie auffahren
oder bitte das ist das wäre jetzt echt
voll voll geil ja-seite 143 und dann
gucke ich mir die hausaufgaben mal an
und dass sie dann ungefähr so aus
ganz ehrlich ich habe keine ahnung
die von mir wollen und eine weitere ganz
ganz schlimme sache die kommt auch noch
das sind jetzt nur so die groben richtig
schlimmen sachen es gibt zwar noch ganz
viele einzelteile die haut vielleicht
ein bisschen schlimm sind aber das ist
jetzt mal so die die top-3 hier im video
und zwar ist das abends wenn man im bett
liegt man ist er hat so bis 11 wenn 12
oder so und will dann abends für ihn
schlafen gehen damit man auch am
nächsten tag fit ist dann denk mir
somalia um halb zwölf solltest du schon
schlafen aber viel spaß was schon 3 15
uhr
da versuche ich jetzt zuschlagen zu
gehen damit ich auch morgen topfit bin
ganz ehrlich das bringt doch eh nix noch
bisschen fernsehen was schon ein
das heißt wieder nur fünf stunden schlaf
ja und man schläft da vielleicht
irgendwann mal so um 1 uhr ein musste
aber halt am gleichen tag auch wieder um
halb sieben aufstehen das hat
fünfeinhalb schon geschlagen und ich bin
einfach mal so müde das kennt ihr
bestimmt auch alle montag ist zwar der
anteil erst mal scheiße aber dann geht's
immer so ne soll hat es einfach ganzen
tag gefegt die hasse ich hasse es
einfach keine ahnung wenn ihr mir dazu
stimmt dann zeigt mir auf jeden fall mit
dem daumen nach oben wenn ihr das auch
so kennen würde mich bei richtig
interessiert schreibt in die kommentare
was ich so am meisten aufregt am sonntag
ansonsten würde ich sagen
jedoch war schön instagram eingeblendet
aber nicht vergessen um nicht mehr zu
verpassen wir sehen uns nächste woche
schon wieder direkt ich weiß nicht wann
wie viele videos kommen auf jeden fall
kommt genug und hier auf der linken
seite geht es weiter mit meinem letzten
video das war mit meinem kumpel zehn
arten von snap chat nutzern richtig geil
geworden ich denke dass auf jeden fall
ab und hier auf der anderen seite mit
meinem keine ahnung lasst euch
überraschen irgendwas was hierzu passt
und ich würde mal sagen wir sehen uns
habe ich schon gesagt leute zschau